faltan dos semanas para las elecciones
que determinarán quién sucederá a la
canciller alemana angela merkel luego de
16 años en el poder y este domingo en un
debate televisivo los 3 candidatos a
sucederlo discutieron sobre algunos de
los temas más importantes de la
actualidad alemana desde la cuarta ola
de la pandemia hasta la lucha contra el
cambio climático o el desarrollo digital
en el país
el candidato bajo mayor presión sin duda
amenazas del bloque conservadora que
también pertenece merkel y que en las
últimas semanas se ha desplomado en las
encuestas por su parte el candidato que
recibió la mayor cantidad de ataques en
el debate de este domingo fue olaf
scholz el actual vicecanciller y
candidato de los socialdemócratas un
partido por el que hace algunos meses
prácticamente nadie habría apostado pero
en los últimos días sorpresivamente ha
pasado a liderar las encuestas en medio
de los dos candidatos anna lenna ve algo
que la candidata de los verdes cuya
principal estrategia consistió en
demostrar cómo ella se diferencia de los
otros dos candidatos cuyos partidos
forman parte de la actual coalición del
gobierno a nivel nacional este debate
demostró que la carrera para merkel
continúa totalmente abierta hasta qué
punto este debate puede ayudar a cambiar
la decisión de los votantes es algo que
solamente podrá empezar a saberse en los
próximos días